un candidato opositor para las
elecciones parlamentarias de este
domingo lauren caballero ha hecho
campaña en su distrito en el norte de
caracas a pesar de que los partidos
opositores convencionales están llamando
a un boicot de las votaciones estoy
totalmente convencido además de que es
la única opción que tenemos frente a esa
disyuntiva de votar o no votar
[Música]
resuelva los problemas miles de
candidatos prometen confrontar al
partido socialista gobernante pero
líderes de oposición los acusan de ser
aliados en la sombra del presidente
nicolás maduro el principal contendor
político de maduro juan guaidó es
reconocido por más de 50 países como el
líder legítimo de venezuela pero bueno
no estará en las papeletas dice que unas
elecciones libres y justas son
imposibles con maduro yo le pido un
favor no lo llame lección
corte a una en la narrativa de una
dictadura violadora de derechos humanos
en lugar de participar why do y sus
aliados promueven un referendo del 7 al
12 de diciembre en el que piden a los
venezolanos rechazar la votación
su ausencia probablemente dará al
partido de maduro el control de la
asamblea nacional la única institución
que todavía no está en sus manos en una
elección nacional
ellos quisieran convertir en plebiscito
les aceptó el reto si ustedes llegan yo
me voy de la presidencia
uno de los candidatos del partido
socialista es el hijo de maduro al igual
que la oposición espera que el próximo
presidente de eeuu joe biden
levante las sanciones que sólo agravan
la severa crisis económica del país